the function f of x is shown in green
the sliding purple window may contain a
section of an anti-derivative of the
function f of x so essentially it's
saying this green function is
potentially the derivative of or part of
this green function is potentially the
derivative of this purple function and
what we need to do is it says where does
the function of the sliding window
correspond to the anti-derivative of our
function the anti-derivative of f of x
usually write as big f of x this is just
saying that f of x is the derivative of
or lowercase f of x is just the
derivative of big f of x so at what
point at what point could the derivative
of the purple function and i'm going to
move the purple function around
where could it be where can the
derivative of that be the green stuff so
just let's just focus on the purple
stuff first
so the derivative we can just view it as
the slope of the tangent line between
this point and this point we see that we
have a constant negative slope and then
we have a constant positive slope so
let's see where where here do we have a
constant negative slope well now here
the slope is zero and it gets more
negative here we have a constant
positive slope not a constant negative
slope here we have a constant negative
slope so maybe it matches up over there
so here
here we have a constant negative slope
but then we don't have a pi on the
purple function we have a positive slope
but where the potential derivative is
here we just have a slope of zero so
this doesn't match up either so it looks
like in this case there's actually no
solution let's see if this works out
yes correct next question
let's do another one a function f of x
is shown in purple the sliding green
window may contain a section of its
derivative so now we're trying to say at
what point of this purple function might
the derivative look like this green
function so in this green function if
this is the function's derivative here
the slope is very negative it goes to 0
and then the slope gets positive so
let's think about it so over here the
slope the slope is just a constant
negative so that won't work
if we shift it over here
our slope is very steep in the negative
direction and then it gets less and less
deep in the negative direction and it
goes all the way and then over here the
slope is zero and over here if this is
the derivative it seems to match up the
slope is zero and then it gets more and
more steep in the positive direction so
this matches up it looks like over this
interval the green function is indeed
the derivative of this purple function
so let's see let's check our answer
correct next question let's do another
one this is exciting
a function f of x is shown in green the
sliding purple window may contain a
section of an anti-derivative of the
function f of x
so now we say let's let's
try to match up this let's match up this
little purple section to its derivative
so the green is the derivative the
purple function is the thing we're
taking the derivative of so if we just
look at the purple we see that we have a
neg a constant negative slope in the
first part of it
then our slope so let me just look for
where i can find a constant negative
slope so here this is a constant
positive slope this is not a constant
slope
this is constant positive okay here's a
constant negative slope let's see if
this works
so over this interval between here and
here my slope is a constant negative
and indeed it looks like a constant
negative and you see it's a constant
negative one and over here you see the
derivative is right at negative one and
it's constant so that part looks good
and then when i look at the purple
function my slope is zero starting off
then it gets more and more steep in the
negative direction and so my slope is
zero and it gets more and more negative
so this indeed seems to match up so
let's check
let's check our answer
yes got it right i could keep doing this
this is so much fun